ja dann fangen wir an grüßen sie sehr
herzlich zum presseberichte über 2020 im
robert-koch-institut mit professor
lothar wieler präsident des robert koch
instituts und dr rexroth leiterin des
lagezentrums noch ein kurzer
organisatorischer hinweis bevor es
losgeht
wir haben diesmal leider keine
gebärdendolmetscherin organisieren
können es war niemand verfügbar aber
phoenix untertitelt und dafür sind wir
sehr dankbar möchten uns auch noch mal
herzlich bedanken
wer weder bitte guten morgen meine damen
und herren man da und herren die lage
die korona lage in deutschland ist nach
wie vor sehr ernst
das infektionsgeschehen nimmt immer noch
praktisch in ganz deutschland zu
allein bis heute 0 uhr wurden annähernd
22.000 fälle an das robert koch institut
übermittelt genau waren es 21 1866 diese
knapp 22.000 fälle können wiederum
natürlich weitere menschen anstecken
die fallzahlen sind also insgesamt
weiterhin sehr hoch die zahl der
schweren verläufe und der
intensivpatienten wird ebenfalls weiter
steigen
auch die zahl der todesfälle wird weiter
beides tritt natürlich erst mit einem
gewissen zeitverzug ein aber das wissen
wir ja inzwischen wir müssen also damit
rechnen dass kliniken an ihre
kapazitätsgrenzen stoßen und wir müssen
auch damit rechnen dass sich das virus
in einen regionen unseres landes
unkontrolliert ausbreitet was mich
vorsichtig optimistisch stimmt ist die
tatsache dass die fallzahlen seit
einigen tagen etwas weniger stark
zunehmen
die kurve geht also etwas weniger steil
nach oben sie flacht sich ab
wir wissen noch nicht ob das eine
stabile entwicklung ist ob sich das
fortsetzt
das werden wir erst noch sehen aber das
zeigt meine damen und herren wir sind
diesem virus nicht hilflos ausgeliefert
wir sind nicht machtlos auch wenn die
fallzahlen im moment sehr hoch sind wir
können diesen anstieg abbremsen und wir
alle können dazu beitragen indem wir
kontakte reduzieren und die aha + l
regeln anwenden
und auch wenn die gesundheitsämter in
vielen fällen den genauen
informationsort nicht mehr
nachvollziehen können so sind ihre
erfolge doch nach wie vor beachtlich und
auch von überragender bedeutung für die
eindämmung dieser pandemie ein beleg für
die erfolgreiche leistung der
gesundheitsämter ist sie auch die
tatsache dass viele tausend menschen in
quarantäne sind und all diese die in
quarantäne sind können keine
infektionsgefahr für andere mehr
darstellen und dass meine damen und
herren das ist neben der einhaltung der
hsr regeln die wichtigste maßnahme der
eindämmung dieser pandemie
die haben wir selbst in der hand die
gesundheitsämter haben eine vielzahl von
konzepten umgesetzt mit denen sie ihre
schlagkraft stetig erhöht haben über die
letzten monate
dazu gehören unter anderem der einsatz
der containment scouts die am
robert-koch-institut ausgebildet wurden
oder der einsatz von soldaten der
bundeswehr die bei der kontakt nach
verfolgen beide eine wichtige rolle
spielen und weiterhin schulen auch viele
gesundheitsämter mitarbeiter aus anderen
verwaltungs zeigen damit die nacht
kontakt nachverfolgen auch nachhaltig
unterstützt wird auch für die nahe
zukunft
ich gebe jetzt das wort an dr ute
rexroth sie ist ärztin und
infektionsepidemiologie und die leute
tier am robert-koch-institut unser
lagezentrum dr rexroth wird ihnen die
aktuellen fallzahlen nun etwas näher
erläutern
jetzt schon gesehen haben seit beginn
der pandemie bis heute also
gesamt 727 1553 kopitz 19 fälle
übermittelt und darunter elf 1982
todesfälle also fast 12.000 todesfälle
wir schätzen ja dass bald etwa 500.000
menschen diese akute infektion
überstanden haben
aber das heißt ja auch dass eben aktuell
ungefähr 260.000 menschen dann noch
erkrankt sind die fallzahlen sind
weiterhin sehr hoch anfang oktober
wurden täglich so zwischen 1000 und 4000
fällen übermittelt und letzte woche
waren zwischen 12.000 und 23.000 fällen
pro tag und der wähler hat das ja schon
gerade gesagt heute eben bis heute 0 uhr
dann auch wieder fast 22.000 fälle
wir berichten ja auch immer die sieben
tages incidents die das eben für die
sieben tage darstellt pro 100000
einwohner und die liegt deutschlandweit
natürlich mit regionalen schwankungen
bei 139 fällen je 100.000 einwohner
ja sie haben es gerade schon gehört die
fallzahlen steigen zurzeit nicht mehr
ganz so steil an wie im oktober das kann
daran liegen dass die strengeren
maßnahmen beginnen zu wirken
das wissen wir aber noch nicht genau das
kann auch mit verursacht seien dadurch
dass die laborkapazitäten langsam
ausgeschöpft sind das muss genau
beobachtet werden
wir beobachten ja auch den sieben tages
er wert also dieser wert den wir schon
immer viel diskutiert haben und der lag
in den letzten tagen leicht unter 1 sie
wissen dass handelt sich um einen
schätzwert da sind unsicherheiten mit
behaftet gestern waren das hieß es er
ist 0,89 und da sagen wir der schwankt
also der liegt wahrscheinlich zwischen
0,28 und 0,97 dass es diese unsicherheit
wir beobachten in den letzten tagen dass
es einen leichten rückschlag gibt also
steht leicht zurückgeht
aber sie sehen die fallzahlen bleiben
weiterhin sehr hoch
ja um ihnen das zu verdeutlichen dass
dieses infektionsgeschehen auch für die
schwere bedeutet schreiben wir zwei
grafiken mitgebracht ich hoffe sie sehen
jetzt gleich die erste grafik bitte
diese einblenden
diese zeigt den verlauf der anzahl der
hospitalisierten also dem krankenhaus
befindlichen fälle nach meldewoche und
auch noch altersgruppe sie sehen hier
rote balken über die letzten wochen
september oktober bis jetzt zum november
rain und vorne im vordergrund eine
schwarze linie das ist insgesamt die
fallzahl die anzahl der fälle insgesamt
und da sehen sie auch dass die sich
jetzt eben zum schluss leicht abgeflacht
hat aber eben weiter zunimmt und sie
sehen im hintergrund roten heller und
dunkler rote balken und das sind eben
ist die anzahl der hospitalisierten pro
woche in der woche und die dunkleren
sind die unter 60 jährigen und die etwas
helleren sind die 60 jährigen und
älteren das muss größer gleich 60 jahre
sein
das hat jetzt in der 45 kalenderwoche
leicht abgenommen
das liegt aber eben auch daran wie herr
wieder sagt dass das ja nachricht man
kommt nicht sofort ins krankenhaus wenn
man erkrankt
und sie sehen insgesamt ist es deutlich
ansteigt und auf der anderen seite auf
der nächsten grafik bitte da gehen wir
zu den todesfällen da sehen sie die
anzahl der todesfälle nach sterbe woche
und altersgruppe wie sollte jetzt als
nächstes kommen ja jetzt kommt sie
glaube ich und da sehen sie ihm auch
über die letzten wochen wie auch die
anzahl der todesfälle hier pro woche
dargestellt eben deutlich zunimmt und
dass da auch jüngere also unter 60
jährige dabei sind aber natürlich ist
der große anteil älter als 60
beziehungsweise auch älter als 80 und
darauf möchte ich jetzt ein bisschen
näher eingehen es sind insgesamt mehr
ältere menschen betroffen also die
inzidenz steigt auch in den höheren
altersgruppen seit wochen an
und bei den über 80-jährigen ist die
jetzt schon bei 123 400.000 es kommen
entsprechend immer mehr menschen ins
krankenhaus weil die ja auch schwerer
franken in der ersten oktoberwoche da
wurden 100 1400 felder spezialisiert und
in der ersten novemberwoche wissen wir
jetzt von rund 4000 und natürlich werden
müssen auch dann immer mehr menschen
intensivmedizinisch behandelt werden
zum vergleich am 8 oktober waren das 487
von den bewussten und aktuell sind es
jetzt mit stand gestern über 3000 3127
patienten
wir haben übrigens den lagebericht ein
bisschen angepasst so dass sie gleich
auf der ersten seite auch sehen können
wie die älteren altersgruppen betroffen
sind und auch wie viele eben von denen
wir wissen dass die aktuelle
intensivmedizinisch betreut werden
müssen
ja und da sind natürlich auch die
todesfälle dabei und da sehen wir dass
immer mehr menschen auch ankurbelt 19
sterben
die anzahl der todesfälle die uns
übermittelt wurden sie uns gerade auf
der grafik gesehen die lag anfang
oktober noch im niedrigen zweistelligen
bereich und jetzt im november im
dreistelligen ja und gestern 261 und
heute 215 todesfälle innerhalb eines
einzigen tages hat schon gesagt dass
diese verläufe immer erst mit verzug
sichtbar werden und dass das deswegen
auch noch ansteigen wird es gibt aber
auch jüngere menschen die
intensivmedizinisch betreut werden auch
wenn die in der regel weniger schwer
erkranken zum glück gibt es dennoch auch
bei milderen verläufen komplizierte
spätfolgen
das reicht von starker müdigkeit und
konzentrationsstörungen auch zu
schwereren symptomen und das wissen wir
aus studien wir können aktuell die
langzeitfolgen ja noch gar nicht
abschließend beurteilen
dann kommt auch natürlich noch hinzu
dass diese hohen fallzahlen die wir
aktuell haben sehr viele kontakte haben
hier will hat schon gesagt die gerade im
quarantäne auch sind und diese menschen
vor allem natürlich im beruflichen
alltag aus das erleben wir überall und
das gibt eine besondere herausforderung
also das stellt nicht nur die
gesundheitsämter unter große
herausforderung diese kontakte alle zu
ermitteln und zu informieren und
den gesundheitsstatus zu fragen sondern
das stellt natürlich auch das
gesundheitswesen insgesamt für sehr
große herausforderung denn wenn
ärztinnen und pfleger ausfallen dann
wird die situation in den krankenhäusern
natürlich zusätzlich verschärft wenn auf
der einen seite die fallzahlen steigen
und auf der anderen seite das personal
abnimmt was sich um die kümmern kann
und deswegen haben wir auch das intensiv
register was wir uns genauer angucken
und da wird ja jetzt wieder darüber
berichten ja meine damen und herren
diesen aspekt der krankenhäuser
insbesondere der intensiv das intensiv
registers also der erfassung derjenigen
die auf intensiv behandelt werden da
möchte ich noch einige daten genauer
vorstellen dass er die wie intensiv
register das ist ein digitales echtzeit
system zur erfassung der intensiv
kapazitäten in dem land und zwar
deutschlandweit tatsächlich bin ich
recht stolz darauf dass für den aufbau
und die entwicklung und auch dass daten
monitoren hier bei uns am
robert-koch-institut stattfinden haben
lassen können wir arbeiten hier sehr eng
zusammen mit denen die wie
fachgesellschaft lassen sie uns die
wichtigsten kennzahlen ganz kurz
anschauen und dazu bitte ich die nächste
grafik einzublenden
diese grafik zeigt ihnen zum einen den
verlauf der krankheitsfälle und zum
anderen auch in einer weiteren
darstellung die kurve derjenigen die auf
intensiv medizin behandelt werden sie
sehen in blau die fälle das sind also ja
inzwischen auf der rechten seite unten
die zeitachse von märz bis november
und auf der rechten seite über 20.000 dp
chs und sie sehen die rote linie das
sind diejenigen die intensivmedizinisch
behandelt werden und man sieht mit stand
elfter november also gestern befand sich
insgesamt von 1289 kliniken die die
daten melden 3127 korrekt patienten in
intensivmedizinischer behandlung und
tatsächlich meine damen und herren sind
das jetzt bereits mehr
intensivmedizinische fälle als im april
und die zahlen haben sich in den beiden
letzt
wochen verdoppelt was hier der grafik
auch noch nehmen können ist dass die
kurve infektionsfälle pro tag das quasi
viele patientinnen patienten immer zwei
wochen später dann auf intensivstationen
zu sehen sind dass wir die zu erwarten
haben da sieht man sehr gut an der
grafik insbesondere im april da ist ein
zweiwöchiger zeitverzug extra den müssen
wir bitte immer im kopf behalten wenn
wir über das nachdenken was in zukunft
in den intensivstationen geschehen wird
im frühjahr waren die infektionszahlen
stärker durch die höheren altersgruppen
geprägt und der wiederanstieg im herbst
war zu anfang im vergleich dazu durch
jüngere altersgruppen geprägt aber wir
sehen eben nun eine zunahme der
infektionsfälle und auch der
hospitalisierten in den altersgruppen
der über 60 jährigen und den letzten
zwei wochen auch noch mal das hat frau
rexroth eben noch mal deutlich
hervorgerufen die kurve dieser coup 19
patientinnen die intensivmedizinisch
behandelt werden müssen muss deshalb
sehr sehr eng beachtet werden und sie
wird natürlich steigen weil die
altersgruppen zugenommen hat und neben
dieser quantitativen meldung und das ist
eine wichtige information und geben und
die kliniken auch die individuelle
einschätzung an der gesamtsituation in
ihrer jeweiligen klinik und diese
bezieht neben der reinen
bettenauslastung die personalsituation
ein die arbeitsbelastung und auch die
raumsituation das will ich ihn in den
nächsten grafik darlegen werde nämlich
über die sommermonate eine sehr stabile
verfügbarkeit der invasiven beatmung
angegeben wurde wechselten in den
letzten vier wochen zahlreiche kliniken
auf den status begrenzte verfügbarkeit
oder gar keine verfügbarkeit und aktuell
meine damen und herren spricht fast die
hälfte der meldenden kliniken meldet
eine solche eingeschränkte verfügbarkeit
an
da sehen sie auf dieser grafik links
haben sie die anzahl der melde- bereiche
und sie sehen vier verschiedene farben
rechts oben die legende
das sind die vier
warum es zu engpässen kommen kann dass
man räume haben die nicht zur verfügung
stehen ein eingeschränkter zugang zu
verbrauchsmaterialien personal das heißt
also dass die anzahl der personen die
die patienten betreuen können nicht
ausreicht oder das beatmungsgeräte nicht
genügend vorhanden sind und das sind die
beiden unteren kurven beatmungsgeräte
und verbrauchsmaterial sehen sie das
eigentlich stabil dass kein engpass
darstellt seit den ganzen letzten
monaten aber wir sehen zum einen dass
die räume einen engpass darstellen aber
vor allen dingen und das ist die gute
grafik sehen wir das eben das personal
zusätzlich und zunehmend einen engpass
darstellt und der grund ist ganz einfach
einer der gründe ist natürlich dass
durch die hohen fallzahlen eben auch
personal infiziert ist oder in
quarantäne geht und das heißt diese
ressource muss man eben auch immer in
die zukunft betrachten je mehr sich
diese pandemie ausbreitet hier mehr
menschen infiziert werden desto mehr
können natürlich auch menschen betroffen
sein die im krankenhaus arbeiten und das
gilt ja für viele andere bereiche des
öffentlichen lebens das heißt also es
kommt zunehmend zu akuten
einschränkungen des betriebs aufgrund
von personalmangel und tatsächlich hat
sich die anzahl der klinik mit dieser
meldung in den letzten vier wochen
verdoppelt rückmeldung aus der intensiv
medizin bestätigen dass jetzt schon der
regelbetrieb in einigen kliniken
eingeschränkt werden muss um personal
für die intensivstation freizusetzen
und hier ist ganz klar der appell hier
darauf müssen sich die kliniken
natürlich vorbereiten und das tut sie
auch meinen daumen tagen weitere zahlen
und informationen zudem intensiv
register finden sie unter www.in tensid
register punkt.de und zwar in form des
tages reports in karten länder tabelle
aber auch in zeitreihen
meine damen und herren lassen sie mich
noch mal zum schluss das wichtigste was
vdr rexroth und ich ihnen heute
vorgestellt haben zusammenfassen
die fallzahlen sind im moment sehr hoch
das führt dazu dass viele menschen
beruflich ausfallen
das auch vergleichsweise viele menschen
schwer und langwierig erkrankt
können möglicherweise spätfolgen
erleiden oder sogar sterben
wir müssen uns darauf einstellen dass
sich die situation in den kommenden
wochen verschärft manche kliniken
könnten an ihre grenzen kommen es ist
möglich dass patienten nicht mehr
überall optimal versorgt werden können
wir müssen daher verhindern dass sich
die situation weiter zuspitzt
das ist meine erwartung und wir tun
alles dafür was in unserer macht steht
um dieses ziel zu erreichen
unser ziel ist es nach wie vor und das
wird es auch für viele monate noch
bleiben meine damen und herren die
infektionen wieder auf ein level zu
bringen mit dem die gesundheitsämter die
krankenhäuser mit dem wir alle umgehen
können
unser ziel ist aber auch dann nach wie
vor so wenige infektionen wie möglich
zuzulassen
und wie schaffen wir das wie können wir
das erreichen
dazu gibt es ein ganzes paket einen
maßnahmen mit dem wir dieser pandemie
uns entgegenstemmen können und das
machen wir auch und ich nenne ihnen noch
einmal die drei wichtigsten maßnahmen
erstens die hhl regeln abstand halten
mindestens ein meter fünfzig
hygieneregeln beachten alltags masken
tragen und zwar meine damen und herren
bitte richtig über mund und nase und
natürlich lüften wo das gegeben ist und
das gilt überall
das heißt also das gilt auch zu hause
wenn sie zum beispiel besuch bekommen
zweitens kontakte reduzieren je weniger
menschen sich treffen
je seltener sie sich treffen desto
weniger chancen geben wir diesem virus
dass es sich zwischen einzelnen menschen
weiter verbreiten können
und drittens und das ist eben fall ganz
wichtig wenn die symptome einer akuten
atemwegsinfektion haben bitte bleiben
sie für mindestens fünf tage zu hause
wenn wir alle diese drei maßnahmen
beherzigen man da unten dann können wir
und dann werden wir auch sehr viele
infektionen verhindern diese maßnahmen
werden uns noch lange begleiten auch
dann wenn es in absehbarer zeit einen
wirkstoff einen wirksamen impfstoff
geben könnte
denn es wird leider dauern
sich alle die das möchten impfen lassen
können
wir sind alle von dieser pandemie
betroffen wie können sie daher nur
gemeinsam bewältigen und meine damen und
herren wir werden sie auch gemeinsam
durchstehen und bewältigen danke ihnen
ja vielen dank herr wille und vor
rexroth dann gehen wir gleich mit den
fragen
wir fangen an mit polnischen ski von dpa
und morgen würden sie mit blick auf die
infektionszahlen denn einen längeren
lockdown geworden als ende november oder
eines schärferen lockdown schon jetzt
volle winski wir betrachten die zahlen
wir analysieren die zahlen jeden tag wir
sehen bislang eine abflachung und wir
wissen das ja erst etwa zwei wochen nach
dem die maßnahmen eingeführt wurden wie
einen richtigen effekt sehen lassen sie
uns warten um diese antworten geben zu
können
wir werden das geschehen dadurch
abbremsen
aber wie schnell wir es abbremsen das
hängt eben in hohem maße auch davon ab
wie wir alle uns an die entsprechenden
verhaltensregeln halten
und darum ist das nicht vorher zu sagen
ich kann nur noch mal an alle
appellieren dass sie mitmachen und dann
reduzieren wir die zahl auf ein maß das
wir hoffentlich wieder beherrschen
können vielen dank
wir gehen zur bild zeitung das muss
passieren damit ihr weihnachten fest im
größeren kreis ab und kann am see
richtwerte anhand derer sie für eine
lockerung des lok bei uns wären auch die
zahlen bei der intensivbetten nun wir
schauen auf alle die zahlen sie wissen
dass es keine richtig harten richtwerte
gibt es gibt nicht das eine ist das eben
jeder dieser werte immer einen
bestimmten bereich nur betracht und es
gibt ja zum beispiel regionen in denen
bestimmte werte ganz anders aussehen wir
haben ja immer
eine maßnahme die für ganz deutschland
gilt die regeln die empfehlungen des
robert koch instituts unter anderem geld
der immer für ganz deutschland
aber natürlich werden sie immer an die
jeweiligen regionalen gegebenheiten
angepasst das heißt also es kann in
einem landkreis zum beispiel so sein
dass die eine zahl noch hoch ist die
andere war schon in einem bereich dass
die zahlen noch zu beherrschen sind und
darum gibt es keine klaren festen
richtwerte wir haben uns vor einigen
monaten vereinbart dass diese zahl der
inzidenz die 50 pro 100.000 eine zahl
ist ab der wie bestimmte maßnahmen
verschärfen
diese zahl hat nach wie vor gültigkeit
wir werden ja auch sehen wie sich zb die
anzahl der gegen entwickelt die im
krankenhaus behandelt werden können
das hängt ja unter anderem auch davon ab
wie viel intensivbetten betrieben werden
können das heißt also alle diese zahlen
müssen eben auch vor ort betrachtet
werden und darum gibt es hier keine
feste richtgröße das muss immer alles
gegeneinander abgewogen werden und es
gibt hier nicht die pauschale eine
bericht zahl die wir für ganz
deutschland ausgeben können wir gehen
zur welt die frau ich habe bestimmt
falsch ausgesprochen
ich hätte auch noch mal eine frage was
nicht in studenzen ich will ihnen ja
deutschlandweit mittlerweile bei 139
nun war ja eigentlich auch das ziel
dessen kanzlerin ausgegeben hatte mit
den ministerpräsidenten dass man durch
diesen schon jetzt auf einen 17 sie
dance von 50 pro monat 1000 kommt
glauben sie das ist überhaupt in den
nächsten wochen irgendwie machbar
ja wie gesagt glaube ist ist aus meiner
sicht auch eine sache die wir mehr für
die religionsgemeinschaften übrig haben
ich hoffe das natürlich wir werden das
sehen also es hängt ist kann es nun mal
sagen wir werden das einfach sehen es
wird sehr schwierig diesen wert zu
erreichen wir haben ja im früher gemerkt
wie lange es gedauert hat bis sich die
zahlen wirklich abgebremst haben
auch das hatte ja einen eine nachlauf
aber ich möchte noch mal
daran erinnern dass ja unabhängig von
dem lockdown leiht den wir jetzt vor
zwei knapp zwei wochen also montag
letzter woche erst dann implementiert
haben das ja schon zwei wochen vorher
auch von den ministerpräsidenten
bestimmte maßnahmen ebenfalls
durchgeführt worden die ja auch sicher
noch dazu führen werden dass infektionen
unterdrückt werden aber ich kann es noch
mal sagen das alles kann uns nur
gelingen wenn wir alle wirklich diese
maßnahmen so gut wie möglich in unserem
beruflichen auch wie auch privaten leben
umsetzen und wir werden das sehen und
dann muss die politik entscheiden wie
sie weiter vorgeht aber wir haben nur
dieses paket und das ist ein großes
paket von maßnahmen die wir alle tragen
müssen dann kriegen wir die zahlen
runter wir haben es ja belegt dass es
geht im frühjahr aber natürlich ist es
im hirn winter schwieriger ganz einfach
deshalb weil eben wir uns mehr in
geschlossenen räumen aufhalten und damit
wird es dem virus leichter gemacht aber
es geht wir können es wenn wir uns nach
wie vor zusammen reißen dann schaffen
wir das und ich bin auch sehr überzeugt
davon
ich weiß auch aus umfragen dass die
mehrheit der deutschen verstehen dass
diese maßnahmen greifen und das ist ein
paket von maßnahmen ist und dass die
alle zusammen viel bereich erreichen
können aber ich kann es nur noch mal
sagen da wir müssen hier noch ein paar
monate wirklich die pobacken
zusammenkneifen und das machen wir auch
und dann können wir das runterbringen
nochmal eine nachfrage wenn ich da herr
professor wieder jetzt sagen sie monate
müssen wir die arschbacken
zusammenkneifen und ist ja eigentlich
dieser lockdown leid nur bis ja noch für
zweieinhalb wochen angesetzt ist das da
machbar auf 50 runterzukommen
wie gesagt ich kann es ihnen nicht sagen
aber auch wenn wir dann runter kommen
wir müssen natürlich auch danach
dieses maßnahmenpaket der aha regeln der
einschränkung von kontakten das müssen
wir auch danach fahren das werden wir
noch den ganzen winter fahren müssen die
frage ist nur in welcher ausprägung das
ist ohne das einhalten von a-ha + l
regeln wird es sicher nicht gehen
diese maßnahmen werden wir noch viele
monate fahren müssen ganz sicher
vielen dank wir gehen zur tagesschau
herr gensing
hallo naja wider sie haben vorhin mal
auf die regionalen unterschiede
hingewiesen
dazu hätte ich eine frage und zwar ist
es ja anfangs auf die großstädte seien
das problem das lässt sich inzwischen ja
nicht mehr so eindeutig sagen angesichts
des infektionsgeschehen es eher ein
gefälle von süden mit sehr hoher
incidents richtung norden
ich wollte wissen ob ihre analysen
hinweise gegen welche faktoren denn eine
rolle spielen was diese besondere
belastung mit inzidenz betrifft ja es
ist natürlich es gibt natürlich eine
assoziation zwischen bevölkerungsdichte
pro quadratkilometer das ist klar also
je mehr menschen eng zusammen sind desto
leichter wird es dem video ist natürlich
gemacht dass das ist sicher so wir haben
in bestimmten fällen aber auch einzelne
ereignisse die wir ja jetzt mit diesem
lockdown leid dann endgültig abgestellt
haben einzelne ereignisse wie zb nehmen
wir jetzt große hochzeiten wo mehrere
hundert menschen hochzeiten haben feiern
dürfen ja auch teilweise oder nehmen wir
in verschiedenen glaubensgemeinschaften
große gottesdienste wo bestimmte regeln
nicht eingehalten wurden also es ist
nach wie vor so dass einfach viel von
diesem geschehen durch große ausbrüche
anfangs dominiert war und das ist dann
natürlich in die anderen
gesellschaftsschichten eingesickert
sozusagen und das ist dann schwer zu
kontrollieren das heißt also es ist nach
wie vor hängt es im zusammenhang damit
dass menschen sich zu häufig treffen und
zu eng und zu lange miteinander umgehen
und der ausgangspunkt war ein große
ausbrüche und die sind dann in die
fläche haben die sich verteilt und das
heißt also wenn wir dann in einzelne
landkreise rhein schauen dann können wir
dort häufig genau nachvollziehen was
dort geschehen ist aber wir können das
nicht immer ja das heißt also die die
die wichtigste nachricht ist nach wie
vor
natürlich ist es in großstädten wo
besonders viele menschen auf engem raum
zusammenleben ist nach wie vor die
infektionsgefahr
größer dadurch dass der raum kleiner ist
und man sich dann mehr trifft und dass
das geht eben unter anderem auch damit
einher dass bestimmte
bevölkerungsgruppen also altersgruppen
einfach mobiler sind sich häufiger
treffen als andere
und dann müssen sie eben auch die
altersstrukturen in den einzelnen
landkreisen anschauen dann sieht man
auch natürlich zusammenhänge zwischen
dem alter der person und dem verhalten
der person das ist nachvollziehbar das
ist ganz klar
und natürlich sehen wir auch inzwischen
dass dadurch dass die schulen
aufgehalten werden wir sehen ja auch
immer mehr ausbrüche in schulen
wir haben inzwischen ich habe es nicht
ganz im kopf aber mehr als 370 ausbrüche
glaube ich die uns allein gemeldet
wurden und wenn sie sich im gestrigen
bericht zb unserem lagebericht von
gestern
da haben wir eine grafik drin dort sind
die inzidenz nach altersgruppen
aufgelistet dann sehen sie zb das auch
die altersgruppe der zehn- bis
19-jährigen inzwischen hohe zahlen
erreicht wenn ich das noch halbwegs im
kopf waren das über eine inzidenz von
über 160 gestern also zum beispiel der
zehn- bis 19-jährigen
das heißt also natürlich ist es auch so
dass das geschehen in die schulen nun
getragen wird und auch aus den schulen
ausgetragen wird das ist ganz klar dass
wir wissen ja schon seit langer zeit das
natürlich auch kinder infiziert werden
können
gott sei dank werden sie in der regel
aber nicht so schwer krank aber wir
wissen dass sie so etwa ab der pubertät
dann auch genauso viel virus ausscheiden
wie erwachsene und damit natürlich auch
das virus weiter tragen können vielen
dank
wir gehen zur taz herr kreutzfeldt und
das macht mich würde interessieren
wir haben ja jetzt in der letzten woche
eine änderung der testkriterien gab
durch das robert koch institut das nicht
mehr getestet wird werde nur leichte
symptome hat sondern nur schwere
symptome oder sind plus kontakt zu
infizierten und auch schulklassen ja
nicht mehr getestet werden wenn es da
einen fall gab sondern quarantäne
geschickt werden mich würde
interessieren wie stark verändert dass
die zahlen die wir sehen also wie
vergleichbar sind die infizierten zahlen
eigentlich noch wenn jetzt die
testkriterien sich so ändern wie stark
steigt aus ihrer sicht durch die
geänderte kriterien die dunkelziffer
ja das ist eine sehr gute frage kreuz
für bin ja schon froh wenn sie mich
nicht zum erhalt fragen auch das ist
eine sehr gute frage
dazu sehe ich alles geklärt ergänzt mich
sicher wenn wir nicht neues vergessen
aber aber sie haben recht
selbstverständlich wird das einen
einfluss haben sollte es zumindest denn
wir wir wünschen dass unsere
empfehlungen umgesetzt werden das können
wir noch nicht sehen das können wir
deshalb noch nicht sehen wir haben ja
immer rund eine woche einen verzug mit
den meldezahlen von dem zeitpunkt wo
menschen sie infizieren und anni test
gemacht wenn wir sehen zurzeit auch
größere vorzüge bei der meldung dadurch
dass eben auch das ergebnis der tests ja
auch später wieder herausgegeben wird
aber sie haben recht ich persönlich gehe
davon aus dass die dunkelziffer aber
auch schon vorher etwas größer geworden
ist weil einfach natürlich die test
kapazitäten am rande sind also man kann
wir haben glaube ich 15 oder 1,4
millionen theoretische nenne sogar mehr
eine theoretische kapazität jetzt von
1,9 millionen erreicht in der letzten
woche aber das sind theoretische
kapazität die gar nicht mehr getragen
werden kann weil es ja auch teilweise
engpässe gibt bei labor materialien das
heißt also ich gehe davon aus dass die
dunkelziffer eigentlich schon seit ein
zwei drei wochen früher etwas größer
geworden ist will die welt gar nicht
mehr alle getestet werden können das ist
schwierigkeit für uns das genau
auszurechnen wir hatten im sommer es
gibt ein paar daten also wohl die studie
von kollegen aus münchen
die haben eine dunkelziffer durch
serologische studien glaube ich von 4
bis etwa 5 berechnet wir selber haben
wir diese hotspot studien durchgeführt
wir sind auch bei einer dunkelziffer von
vier bis fünf etwa ich denke wenn ich
das richtig in erinnerung habe auch die
studie heinsberg da war das auch etwa so
der faktor also wenn man fünffache
dunkelste vorgenommen hat dann würden
wir jetzt also ich zumindest jetzt
ausgehen dass die etwas steigt wir
können es aber nicht genau beziffern
aber der entscheidende punkt ist der
kreuzung das ist der entscheidende punkt
also wir haben einfach sehr sehr hohe
zahlen und diese zahlen müssen wir
runter kriegen und wir werden natürlich
sehen wenn wir runter kriegen wir haben
auch ein
den bitte ich sie auch in meinem kopf zu
halten bei dem ganzen schätzen wir haben
den faktor der positiven und der ist
nach wie vor gestiegen jede woche ich
glaube wir haben heute oder diese woche
7,88 prozent positiven raten das heißt
also obwohl die dunkelziffer auch steigt
steigt immer noch der anteil der
positiven tests also es geht einfach
jetzt prinzipiell darum wir haben ein so
hohes maß erreicht das wir runter
drücken kannst du nicht kontrollieren
wie hoch die dunkelziffer auch immer
sein muss wir müssen uns diesen
realitäten stellen und eine dunkelziffer
die haben wir ja sicher nicht das ist
nämlich die ziffer derjenigen die
intensivmedizinisch behandelt werden und
die im krankenhaus behandelt werden
da haben wir eine sehr realistische zahl
und an der sollten wir uns immer halten
aber die da gucken wir ja immer zwei
wochen nach hinten also das was wir
heute sehen das ist der status von den
menschen die vor zwei wochen sich da
angesteckt haben dorthin gekommen
das heißt also in zwei wochen sehen wir
das ergebnis von dem was heute geschieht
und darum ist das für uns auch eine sehr
sehr relevante größe die wir mit
einberechnet müssen korrekt sie was zur
gänze wesentlichen werden wir
spezifischer testen
dann sollte eben der anteil der
positiven ansteigen also nutzt man die
tester zielgerichteter dann kann es sein
dass weniger milde fälle erkannt werden
oder auch symptomlose das heißt wir
würden in dem fall seien eben einen
weniger starken anstieg sehen und eine
zunahme der schweren der landwirt des
anteils der schweren verläufe weil da
doch mit einer höheren
wahrscheinlichkeit sichergestellt ist
dass die auch gefunden werden
das würde man dann da daten danke ich
hätte noch eine zweite frage darf ich
oder soll ich mich wieder hinten
anstellen ja
nachfrage ist toll er sich ein bisschen
andere ist aber genau ich bin ich bin
noch interessieren sie haben eben gesagt
dass es verstärkt auch zu beobachten ist
dass das geschehen in die schulen
getragen wird und bei den kindern im
schulalter die inzidenz hochsteigt was
würden sie von der konsequenz daraus
ziehen würden sie in den schulen
besseren schutz noch erforderlich sehen
würden sie für eine wieder halbierung
der schulklassen und abwechselnd
unterrichten studieren oder sogar zu
schließen
also was ist was folgern sie daraus naja
das robert-koch-institut hat ja schon
ich weiß nicht wie oft die empfehlungen
erweitert ich glaube die aktuelle und
ich bin mir sicher die aktuelle version
die auf unserer homepage ist also die
aktuelle empfehlung für schulen sind ja
vom zwölften oktober und dort haben wir
einen ganz klaren stufen plan erstellt
dieser stufen plan ist das was gilt das
heißt also wir hatten von vornherein
gesagt und wir haben ja im sommer auch
ich glaube ich selber hab sogar mehrfach
auch hier in diesem presse briefen
darauf hingewiesen dass doch bitte die
schulen konzepte entwickeln sich darauf
vorbereiten wenn die schulen wieder
geöffnet werden dass sie für jene
konzepte vor wald ich kann nur
appellieren an alle dass sie diese
hygiene konzepte auch wirklich strikt
durchziehen
die sind in unserem papier gelistet und
ich weiß natürlich nicht welche schulen
wie intensiv diese konzepte wirklich
beraten
aber ich weiß zum beispiel dass in
berlin ja jetzt seit einiger zeit auch
das tragen von masken verpflichtend ist
das ist eine wichtige maßnahme und ich
mich ich kann ihnen nicht sagen wieviel
schulen diese konzepte umsetzen aber ich
kann nur alle dringend aufrufen diese
konzepte mit aller stringenz auch
wirklich durchzusetzen
es gibt ja auch immer wieder versuche zu
zum beispiel dass masken tragen in
zusammenhang zu bringen mit mit einer
geringeren sauerstoff versorgen
da haben sich die ärzte schaffen und
fachleute sehr eindeutig geäußert dass
dies nicht der fall ist es gibt auch
immer wieder begründungen das masken
vielleicht dazu tragen dass menschen
psychisch belastet werden da gibt es bei
kindern ebenfalls keinerlei hinweis
bislang also die konzepte und das ist
vielleicht deshalb noch mal danke dass
sie das fragen wir können natürlich die
besten konzepte haben wenn sie nicht
umgesetzt wenn helfen sie nicht ja sie
müssen implementiert werden und dann ich
hatte gestern ein ganz interessantes
gespräch mit einem schülersprecher hier
in berlin herr kamp der
im senat mit mir über das thema
gesprochen oder mit und über das thema
gesprochen hat natürlich erwarten die
schüler auch dass das durchgesetzt wird
und dass das auch kontrolliert wird und
das heißt also das ist ein
entscheidender punkt den ich vielleicht
noch sagen möchte
wir müssen diese maßnahmen natürlich
auch durchsetzen kontrollieren und
entsprechend sanktioniert beginns im
südwestrundfunk verschmäht johannsen
guten tag herr wiener ich habe noch eine
frage nachfrage zu der grafik der
hospitalisierten die sie gezeigt haben
vorhin sie am absolute zahlen der
hospitalisierten gezeigt auch
eingeblendet wenn ich es richtig sie
zeigt die tabelle klinische aspekte die
sie immer dienstags zeigen dass ja nicht
mal mehr von der hälfte der fälle
überhaupt angaben dazu vorhanden sind dh
diese statistik ist wenn ich das richtig
sie unterschätzt sie vollkommen die
tatsächliche anzahl der im krankenhaus
zu behandeln cupid 19 patienten ist es
richtig also davon müssen wir ausgehen
ja dass die dass wir im meldewesen eine
unterschätzung des anteils und und der
anzahl haben die tatsächlich aus
vitalisiert sind für das intensiv für
den intensivbereich haben wir ja das
ging auch noch eben diese
sondererfassung es ist einfach so dass
da ja nach ermittelt werden muss muss um
diese daten noch nachträglich zu erheben
der fall wird ja hoffentlich früher
bekannt bevor er hospitalisiert ist
möglichst früh das ist ja dass
allgemeiner anliegen und wenn er erst
mal erkannt ist die fälle ermittelt sind
dann ist das eben ein sonderaufwand noch
mal nachzufragen zu gucken wo ist denn
der jetzt ist er im krankenhaus ist er
schon wieder entlassen und so weiter und
man muss wirklich sagen dass die
gesundheitsämter natürlich absolut an
ihre kapazitätsgrenzen oder auch weit
darüber hinaus bearbeiten und das ist
jetzt den absoluten die absolute
priorität hat die kontakte zu ermitteln
und insbesondere den wohlhabenden
gruppen bei den
älteren in den alten und pflegeheimen
die cluster zu identifizieren und da
kann man nicht mehr jeder informationen
zu jedem einzelfall zu jedem zeitpunkt
noch hinterherlaufen
das müssen wir einfach akzeptieren
deswegen haben sie völlig recht
diese sieben prozent die wir da haben 67
prozent das ist vermutlich eine
unterschätzung
ja ich hätte noch nachfrage dazu india
wider
diese daten sind aber jetzt zentral sie
haben sie gerade schon erläutert für die
frage wirkt der look down
warum gibt es diese daten nicht ein in
ergänzung im intensiv register hätte man
ja das register erweitern können auch
auf patienten auf station und wie
schätzen sie das ein wie können sie mit
diesen zahlen in den in den herzen den
winter jetzt gehen woran orientieren sie
sich wenn diese zahlen gar nicht
verlässlich aufgearbeitet werden können
von den gesundheitsbehörden
naja also dass die wie intensiv register
ist ja wirklich in echtzeit register und
es gibt natürlich schon vergleichszahlen
an quasi quotienten wie viel wenn da in
den intensivbetten soundsoviel behandelt
werden wie viel werden dann in den
krankenhäusern behandelt das gibt es
schon schätzwerte aber sie haben recht
das ist eine zahl die wir eben nicht
umfänglich haben und die kann nicht
erfasst werden wir sind froh dass wir
überhaupt einen intensiv register haben
meines wissens ist es das einzige
weltweit und das gibt uns sehr viel
information
ich möchte vielleicht noch eine sache
ergänzen zu den fällen die auch im
krankenhaus behandelt werden also wir
haben verschiedene sogenannte sentinel
systeme von denen wir ja auch über die
jahre viel erfahrung haben das geht in
erster linie ging es uns da immer um die
krippe die wir ja sehr gut monitoren und
zu welchen und da haben wir vier systeme
die wir anschauen und ein system davon
ist zum beispiel das wo wir schwere
lungenentzündungen betrachten das sind
sentinel sind also dinge die uns einen
einblick geben aus den wie hoch rechnen
können und nur ein hinweis diesbezüglich
wir haben in den letzten wochen
einige hundert fälle dort und wir haben
dann zum beispiel eine altersverteilung
bei diesen sentinel und zwar heißt dass
sari das sind schwere akute
respiratorische infektionen wie
lungenentzündungen wo menschen im
krankenhaus behandelt werden müssen
und da haben wir in einblicken aus also
1 1 das ist kein repräsentative daten
oder wir können das ungefähr einschätzen
was sehen wir dort
da sind natürlich immer die mehrzahl der
patienten sind immer diejenigen die alt
und hoch altrich sind aber unter denen
sehen wir sage ich mal 15 prozent etwa
von denen hatten in den letzten wochen
infektion mit dem saas koch 2 virus die
jüngeren altersgruppen ich glaube wir
hatten letzte woche so eine grafik in
unserem situationsbericht bei den
jüngeren ist es aber so dass sind zwar
weniger jüngere patienten die wegen
lungenentzündung behandelt werden aber
von den hatten bis zu 40 prozent wurden
behandelt wegen saß koch 2
das heißt also diese daten nutzen wir
auch nach und dann haben wir noch die
anderen am sentinel also diese
respiratorischen infektion die
arztbesuche
wir haben eine reihe von schätzt zahlen
die uns gute dienste tun und wir haben
noch ein 1 and email wo wir von praxen
aus deutschland proben ein geschickt
bekommen aus den revieren isolieren und
hier sehen wir eben auch ein anstieg der
saas kopf zwei werden also alle diese
parameter haben wir den letzten jahren
extra etabliert um daraus aussagen
treffen zu können und wir wissen diese
aussagen durch die erfahrung der letzten
jahre sehr gut einzuschätzen das hilft
uns schon
wir gehen zur frau satori wdr
hallo guten tag können sie mich hören
anfang der woche wurde jetzt einen
vorschlag oder eine empfehlung
veröffentlicht stiko leopoldina und
deutsche ethikrat wie das wenn es mein
impfstoff gibt wer zuerst geimpft werden
soll und die erste priorität haben
besonders wohl gerade personen angehören
oder mitarbeiter des gesundheitswesens
haben die zweite priorität angesichts
der grafik die sie jetzt eben gezeigt
haben wo man sieht dass jetzt schon die
hohen infektionszahlen auch auf die
medizinische personal durchschlägt und
was das bedeutet für die versorgung von
kranken würden sie nicht sagen dass es
sinnvoller wäre dass angehörige des
gesundheitswesens dass die auf die erste
priorität kommen ich bin erstmal die
ärzte und pfleger eben
damit die sich um alle kranken kümmern
kann also das ist ja eine stellungnahme
die über die letzten sechs wochen
erarbeitet wurde und die gibt einen
rahmen vor
und ich bin den denjenigen die diese
stellungnahme durchgeführt haben sehr
sehr dankbar
das war ja im auftrag von bundesminister
sparen eine sehr sehr wichtige
initiative die ein rahmen gesteckt hatte
und dieser rahmen ist klar es geht auf
jeden fall um diese zwei gruppen an
vorderster stelle das sind die wohl
haben selber und diejenigen die sich um
die wohlhabenden kümmern
das hängt dann natürlich im detail von
anderen faktoren noch ab das ist ja
keine finale stellungnahme so ist eine
stellungnahme einordnung die finale
empfehlung die wird er die ständige
impfkommission dann machen wo fachleute
sitzen die auch über modellierungen und
vor allen dingen natürlich dann auch
unter einbeziehung der wirklich harten
daten von diesen impfstoffen wir haben
ja noch keiner richtig harten daten wir
haben jetzt erste und zwar super
ermutigende daten dieses impfstoffes von
bei und techteam mit pfizer zusammen
dann produziert wird das sind sehr sehr
ermutigende und hervorragende daten aber
die sind vorläufig wir sind nicht final
ausgewertet und es hängt sehr viel davon
ab welche anderen impfstoffe ja
vielleicht auch noch auf den markt
kommen wir müssen einfach sagen dass
abhängig vom impfstoff der dann
zugelassen ist und abhängig von der
menge dieses impfstoffes dann sich
regina ändern können wir wissen noch
nicht genau welcher impfstoff zb bei
alten und hochaltrigen eine stärkere
immunität vielleicht induziert als bei
denjenigen die diese menschen dann
betreuen also das heißt da ist noch
sicher luft drin aber das wird die stiko
lässt sich final klären das hängt ab von
der anzahl der impfstoffe es hängt ab
von davon welcher impfstoff denn in
welcher zahl verfügbar ist das ist noch
nicht final entschieden das haben wir
haben ein wirklich großartiges
rahmenwerk vorliegen und das ist auch
wichtig denn die diskussion müssen wir
natürlich führen in den letzten nächsten
wochen und monaten es wird
sehr viele menschen geben die geimpft
werden möchten es wird dann nicht für
alle am anfang impfstoff zur verfügung
gestellt wir müssen das groß diskutieren
welche reihenfolge werden wie warum und
das ist glaube ich einer der größten
herausforderung vor dem wir dann in den
nächsten wochen stehen neben der reinen
eindämmung dieser pandemie die uns ja
auch schon durchaus kraft kosten wird
dankeschön
wir gehen zu web de gmx hallo hallo web
de gmx wären sie uns gut da gibt es
offenbar ein technisches problem dann
gehen wir zu biermann medizin frau oder
herr horst holzhäuser hochhäuser hallo
gesundheitsminister jens spahn hat
bereits ende september angekündigt dass
es in absehbarer zeit corona tests für
den heimgebrauch geben solle
und nun hat auch joe biden einen großen
wo lauter selbst ist in den usa
angekündigt meine frage daher an sie
beide
was genau muss passieren damit auch in
deutschland billige und einfach
anwendbare tipps zu den heimgebrauch
verfügbar werden
sie könnten doch das von ihnen erwähnte
bündel an maßnahmen sinnvoll ergänzen
zur pandemie bekämpfung ja absolut für
hochhäuser
wir unterscheiden zwischen zwei tests
unter diesen sogenannten schnelltests
das eine sind tests die bereits auf dem
markt sind die aber natürlich nach wie
vor noch von fachleuten durchgeführt
werden unter der kontrolle und und damit
auch sichtbar sind für uns und auch dann
für das gesundheitsamt und das
gesundheitswesen und diese test die sie
ansprechend ja die sind ebenfalls in der
entwicklung und die werden auch kommen
ich kann ihnen nicht sagen wann die
kommen aber ich kann ihnen folgendes
sagen ein aspekt der für uns von
überragender bedeutung ist auch hier ist
es wichtig gut zu kommunizieren diese
tests müssen natürlich eine qualität
haben mit der wir dann arbeiten können
sicher es gibt keinen test der so eine
hohe qualität also so hohe prädiktive
werte qualitätsmerkmale hat wie die pcr
die pcr wird der standard bleiben und
wird für bestimmte entscheidungen immer
noch maßgeblich bleiben unter anderem um
auch testergebnisse mit schnelltests zu
verifizieren zu überprüfen ob sie
wirklich stimmen die anderen tests also
wohl die jetzigen antigen tests schnell
test als auch die zukünftigen werden
niemals die qualität erreichen die die
pcr hat in den nächsten monaten
also das ist stand heute so dass das
müssen wir im kopf haben das heißt wir
müssen dann genau überlegen wo wir sie
einsetzen und wo wir sie nicht einsetzen
und das kann ich auch nicht jetzt
hundertprozentig beantworten weil es
wirklich von der qualität abhängt mir
ist nur wichtig ist wäre nicht gut wenn
alle möglichen tests die nicht
ordentlich validiert sind geprüft werde
dann einfach genommen werden
herangezogen und das ergebnis dann dazu
führt dass man irgendwelche schlüsse
daraus zieht die müssen eine qualität
haben und das ist nicht so trivial die
tests in der kürze der zeit gut zu
validieren denken sie daran wie lange
wir gearbeitet haben bis wir die
entsprechenden tests zum beispiel bei
der hiv diagnostik eingeführt haben das
war ein langer weg und die sind sehr
sehr gut validiert wurden vielen dank
ihr problems noch mal bei web.de gmx.net
das klappt irgendwie nicht mit der
stummschaltung aufzuheben gut waren
versuch wert wir gehen zu herrn pencil
sagen sie noch mal welche redaktionen
sie vertreten bitte deutschen apotheker
zeitung pencil hallo hallo sehr geehrte
professor will sie haben gesagt die test
kapazitäten sind hierzulande an der
grenze und die sagten dass sie diese
tests unterscheiden für das fachpersonal
die teske ziel durch wenn sehen sie sind
es als eine gute option an apotheker mit
der zielgerichteten kreuz auch care
testungen zu beauftragen das ist eine
politische entscheidung die ich die ich
nicht beantworten kann
das ist eine politische entscheidung ich
denke wenn die wenn die kapazitäten
ausgeweitet werden müssen dann werden
die entscheide sich überlegen wie sie
das machen und wenn das notwendig ist
dann gibt es verschiedene optionen
prinzipiell gibt es optionen aber über
die habe ich nicht zu entscheiden
spencer glaube ich richtig schönen
brauch ich habe eigentlich zwei
verhandeln daran es geht um die ging man
weist in der letzten jahres genau zwei
wochen ebenso noch downlight trotzdem
steigen
irgendwie die zahlen mehr infekt ihren
infiziert jetzt ist die frage weil man
sieht ihm die schüler müssen in
deutschland mit verschiedenen bahnen
straßenbahnen und bussen die vollgepackt
mit menschen sind kinder und erwachsene
und dann werden die über stunden in der
schule mit masken unterricht ist das
nicht ein grund wieso diese zahlen kreis
diese lockdown zwei anleihen zum
schweigen bringen die in geschäfte und
auf der straße in den zentren muss man
mit masken rumlaufen
aber deine kinder zur schule gehen oder
wieder nach hause die sind folgen auch
ein sicher fand hier ist also danke für
diese frage
wir möchten doch mal sagen wir können
nicht immer im einzelnen fall
nachvollziehen wo sich die menschen
angesteckt haben zurzeit gehen wir davon
aus dass die gesundheitsämter und noch
eintritt ein viertel etwa nachvollziehen
können also drei viertel weiß man nicht
genau aber wir haben natürlich schon
zahlen
die hatte ich beim letzten mal auch
vorgestellt wo nach unserem wissen also
nach den zahlen die uns die
gesundheitsämter zur verfügung stellen
nach diesem wissen was eine
eingeschränkte wissen ist aber trotzdem
ein aussagefähiges wissen ist wo sich
die menschen anstecken und wir haben
bislang
keinen hinweis darauf dass diese
öffentlichen verkehrsmittel eine
wichtige rolle spielen das können wir
nicht ausschließen aber wir wissen es
nicht genau es spricht bislang nichts
dafür
wir wissen aber dass wir natürlich auch
an diesen öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln
masken pflicht haben inzwischen
deutschlandweit so das heißt also dass
sich dort durch das tragen der maske
dass dort das infektionsgeschehen auf
jeden fall reduziert wird und reduziert
werden muss und kann
aber das gelingt natürlich nur auch wenn
sich alle an diese masten pflicht halten
und das ist ja auch einer der appelle
die wir immer wieder hier verbreiten
also es gibt verschiedene settings das
sagen geschichten umgebungen und in
denen diese maßnahme neben eingehalten
werden müssen
und das ist natürlich ein setting eine
umgebung für die maßnahme nach bestem
wissen und gewissen eingehalten werden
müssen und da in diesen öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln man nicht immer den
abstand halten kann
auf der anderen seite ist in der regel
die lüftung ganz gut weil ja gerade u
bahnen s bahn ja auch immer wieder oft
halten und dann durch gelöst wird aber
gerade da ist es deshalb so wichtig dass
die masken wirklich getragen werden und
zwar auch richtig getragen wenn dann
kann man damit das risiko der
übertragung reduzieren
vielen dank henrike roßbach noch sagen
welches medium sie vertreten
ich würde gern früher mal errechnet
wurde mit 50 als der kritischen maßzahl
finden sie das nach wie vor sicher und
richtig bei einem liegen welt wer zu
gucken weil er sehr klar ist obwohl sich
die umstände sowohl in den
gesundheitsämtern als auch mit dem
wissen um das virus verändert haben
ja also ich antworte mal wir wir gucken
ja wirklich nicht nur auf diesen wert
sie haben völlig recht also einen
einzelnen grenzwert das hat ja auch
schon ausgeführt nur zu beobachten und
sich da unabhängig von der
epidemiologischen lage insgesamt nur
darauf zu fixieren das ist natürlich
nicht der weg den wir beschreiten
es ist trotzdem ein wichtiger wert weil
er eben diese diesen aktuelleren
zeitraum besser wiedergibt als jetzt zum
beispiel diese kumulativen zahlen
und es ist auch ganz interessant dass zu
vergleichen in der region den regionen
in den bundesländern und über die
altersgruppen und es gibt da schon
hinweise aber sich jetzt nur auf einen
grenzwert zu versteifen mit 50 je 100000
ist aus unserer sicht auch jetzt nicht
sehr zielführend die landkreise sind ja
auch sehr unterschiedlich aufgestellt
die bevölkerung ist einfach
unterschiedlich der nenner ist total
unterschiedlich und alleine daher ist
die vergleichbarkeit eben begrenzt
eigentlich also aber es ist trotzdem
einer der wichtigen werte die die wir
uns ansehen und an denen wir uns
orientieren können die erst möglich
zeigen was in den letzten tagen woche in
der letzten woche passiert
ich hätte noch eine kleine zweite frage
und zwar sind sie eigentlich überrascht
dass die tage jetzt noch so hoch sind
oder ist das genau das womit sie
gerechnet
also wir haben schon damit gerechnet
dass das im herbst winter wieder zunimmt
also die dieses virus ist da es in der
bevölkerung und wir sehen was in unseren
nachbarländern passiert deutschland ist
dann keine insel der glückseligen wo das
nicht hinkommt sondern es ist von mensch
zu mensch übertragbar und jeder mensch
der mit kontakt mit anderen menschen hat
der kann sich damit anstecken und
deswegen war für uns schon absehbar dass
die fallzahlen wieder steigen würden
ich möchte da aber sagen
wir sehen ja auch trotz dieser starken
fallzahlen hohen falls sein dass die
maßnahmen in einer gewissen weise doch
wirken
wir hätten ja eine nährwert von drei bis
vier zu erwarten wenn die maßnahme gar
nicht wirken würden das heißt diese
differenz wir kämpfen jetzt mit der 1
wir sehen selbst wenn es etwas über 1
ist schießt nach oben das ist natürlich
unerfreulich aber es könnte viel
schlimmer nach oben schießen und das ist
ein großer erfolg der der bevölkerung zu
verdanken ist ein menschen die sich
schon halten auch an die regeln
es reicht noch nicht ganz aber es zeigt
dass es hilft also dass wir auf dem
richtigen weg sind und dass wir dass wir
die schlimmsten szenarien verhindern
können wenn wir das wirklich alle ernst
nehmen
wir gehen zu hören rinke und wenn sie
noch sagen welches medium sie fährt
andreas hintke reuters hallo immer
wieder ich hätte ganz gerne nochmal
gefragt nach dem ort der infektion es
gibt ja auch stamford jetzt so eine neue
studie die haben mobilitäts daten
ausgewertet und schließen daraus dass
restaurants eben doch fitnessstudio sie
noch ein paar andere orte erhöhte
infektionen sein können oder orte wo
sich super spyder ihren verbreiten
können
ich weiß dass er gesagt hat dass die
dunkelziffer bei mehr als 50 prozent
liegt wird die gesundheitsämter das
gesagt haben aber wie beurteilen sie
jetzt diese stanfour und studiert die
anlass das neu nachzudenken und warum
können in deutschland solche mobilen
teams da nicht auch so ausgewertet
herr rinke also diese studien
überraschen nicht also ich bin mir sehr
sicher dass man auch mit wirklich mit
ganz normalem menschenverstand wenn man
einfach nur sich mal in ruhe hinsetzt
und überlegt wie wird dieses virus 1
übertragen dann wird einem klar wenn
eine person die infiziert ist in der
nähe einer anderen person ist und mit
dieser person spricht mit sehr intensiv
sich auseinandersetzt
lacht also beim sprechen beim atmen wird
dass wir uns aus geschehen und je
nachdem wie intensiv man spricht und
atmet und beim singen am allermeisten
wird das virus ausgeschieden ist ganz
klar dass dort wo menschen
zusammenkommen
das dort einfach ein infektionsrisiko
besteht und darum ist da die die
empfehlung des robert koch-instituts
ganz einfach so wenig wie möglich
menschen an so wenig wie möglich orten
zusammenkommen ob das nun im restaurant
ist ob das in einer bar ist wo auch
immer das ist überall dort wo wir das
vermeiden können tun wir gutes und das
gilt für alle ort und dann muss sich die
gesellschaft halt überlegen welche orte
sind die die wie viel so relevant halten
dass wir die halt aufrechterhalten
müssen und diesen weg ist man ja hier
gegangen und deshalb ist das keine
überraschende studie die fragen warum
wir das nicht machen können wir haben ja
ein mobilitäts index wir haben
aggregierter anonymisierte daten diesen
mobility report den haben wir immer
online denen können wir ja auch weiter
verfeinern
auf ebene runter von einzelnen von
einzelnen stadtteilen und so wir können
denen sie heute sagen weißt du ob sie
das wissen von rexroth wie feingliedrig
wie den machen können
ich gehe mal davon aus dass wir das
sicher nicht so machen können das war
damit wirklich solche feingliedrigen
daten haben dass das wird allein schon
der datenschutz nicht ermöglichen da
sind aggregiert und anonymisiert
aber wir können denen eben die die
infektionszahlen der nicht direkt
zuordnen sondern wir müssen wir das
können wir vielleicht modellieren da
haben sie recht aber jetzt völlig
unabhängig von diesem
ansatz der wissenschaftlich gut richtig
und wichtig ist das ist mit gesundem
menschenverstand ist das nachvollziehbar
dass es so ist ich möchte das noch
folgendermaßen ergänzen wenn sie ins
vereinigte königreich schauen dort haben
wir ja wirklich eine sehr dramatische
entwicklung und wenn sie sich die zahlen
anschauen dort wurde anfang september
wurde im vereinigten königreich eine
initiative durchgeführt um das leben in
pubs wieder zu ermöglichen und zu
intensivieren dort wurde unter anderem
incentives gesetzt also das glaube ich
zum beispiel bestimmte an bestimmten
wochentagen oder so das essen nur noch
die hälfte kostete damit wieder besucher
in die box kommen wenn sie sich im
nachhinein anschauen das hat dazu
geführt dass die pops wieder besucht
wurde das hat dazu geführt dass
restaurants intensiver besucht wurden
und sie sehen dass von diesem zeitpunkt
an dass es durchaus einen zeitlichen
zusammenhang gibt zwischen dem anzahl
der steigenden inflation und diesen
maßnahmen und nochmals ist es ist
einfach mit gesundem menschenverstand
plausibel dass wenn menschen gerade dort
wo sie gerne sind wo sie intensiv
freudig zusammen sind gerade dort wo sie
ausgelassen sind und dann natürlich
abstand auch nicht mehr einhalten auch
dort wo alkohol getrunken wird und wir
wissen dass wir alle aus unserem
privaten kreis überall dort wo man dann
halt unvorsichtiger wird dann hat dieses
virus einfach eine größere chance das
ist das ist einfach so und die orte die
sind überall dort wo menschen
zusammenkommen egal was das dann für
setting sind habe ich kurz nachfragen
was heißt denn das für die zeit nach
müsste man dann die gene regel so dass
von mir bereich nochmals verschärfen
na ja ich hatte das hier schon mal
gesagt ich bin mir also ich kann das ja
nicht für ganz deutschland sagen aber
ich sag mal so ich weiß dass es
restaurants gibt die wirklich tolle
hygiene konzepte gemacht haben die auch
überprüfbar sind ich weiß dass es
theater gibt die tolle lüftungen und
tolle gene konzepte haben aber diese
konzepte müssen eben auch dann überprüft
werden
sie müssen nicht nur angekündigt werden
sie müssen auch überprüft werden sie
müssen auch eingefordert werden sie
müssen dann von den von der exekutive
von den ordnungsämtern eben dann auch
wirklich dafür gesorgt wenn das sie
implementiert werden und wenn sie nicht
implementiert wird
dann sollten sie auch sanktioniert
werden denn wenn ich mich zumindest an
die letzten wochen erinnere hatte ich
nicht das gefühl dass in jedem
restaurant und und in jeder kneipe diese
regeln auch umfänglich umgesetzt wurden
das heißt also wir müssen auch immer
noch unterscheiden zwischen der ansage
dass man ein konzept hat und dem
umsetzen des konzeptes da ist meiner
ansicht nach noch viel luft nach oben
und ich gehe mal davon aus dass diese
implementierung auch einfach stärker
überprüft werden und auch dann
entsprechend sanktioniert werden muss
wenn sie nicht geschieht
wir kommen zur letzten anfrage herr
buhre von planet interview
vielen dank ich hoffe sie hören mich ja
danke ich meine frage nochmal zu den
todesfällen über den sommer gab es ja
berichtet dass so etwa 50 prozent der
verstorbenen in pflegeheimen lebten zum
einen wie hoch ist dieser anteil im
moment und dann wurde er mitte oktober
durch herrn spahn angekündigt das es so
in alten- und pflegeheim flächendeckende
tests geben soll wurde das nun bereits
umgesetzt also zum einen wie hoch dieser
anteil und passiert das jetzt inzwischen
mit den tests also ich habe mir also sie
haben ja auch nicht die tabelle also wir
haben ja in dem bericht haben wir in
unserem situationsbericht haben wir auch
immer eine tabelle drin wo wir die daten
die uns übermittelt wurden bezüglich der
wenigen die in bestimmten einrichtungen
leben also in krankenhäusern arbeiten
oder dort versorgt werden in kitas
kindergärten schulen oder in
pflegeeinrichtungen
obdachlosenunterkünften und so da haben
wir verschiedene zahlen
den können wir entnehmen wie viel
gemeldet wurde und wie viel darin
verstorben sind nehmen wir jetzt mal §
36 pflegeeinrichtungen
obdachlosenunterkünfte
einrichtung zur gemeinschaftlichen
unterbringung von asylsuchenden sonstige
massenunterkünften dort wurden insgesamt
25.000 die dort betreut untergebracht
waren wurden positiv getestet und die
von denjenigen die dort arbeiten wurden
rund 14.000 positiv getestet und
verstorben sind von den betreuten
untergebrachten in diesem zeitraum der
letzten monate etwas mehr als 4000
mitmenschen und von denen die dort
gearbeitet haben 45 also diese zahlen
liegen uns vor zu den tests
wir wissen dass es viele einrichtungen
gibt die das tun wie also tests benutzen
aber ob das flächendeckend ist ich weiß
nicht ob sie nur noch was ergänzen
erfassen das jetzt nicht systematisch
wir hören das aber aus den bundesländern
sind die konzepte auch unterschiedlich
es ist insgesamt natürlich im frühjahr
ein sehr hoher anteil gewesenen
ausbruchsgeschehen in alten- und
pflegeeinrichtungen die auch zu sehr
hohen opferzahl dann geführt haben und
das ist eigentlich eine große
erfolgsgeschichte wie das gelungen ist
die in den einrichtungen das wieder
runter zu kriegen und auch unten zu
lassen und es wurde sehr sehr viel
getestet sowohl bewohner als auch
pflegende und es wird auch weiter da
sehr viel getestet sehr genau drauf
geguckt wir sehen trotzdem jetzt auch
wieder ein zunehmend fälle bei alten und
pflegende altenheimen und pflegeheim in
einrichtungen auch in krankenhäusern ist
aber ich denke schon dass da sehr sehr
gute arbeit geleistet wird und das ist
eben noch deutlich schlimmer sein könnte
also eigentlich ist das ist der bereich
einer der natürlich extrem wichtig ist
auf den ganz genau geguckt werden muss
und wo auch wirklich viel erreicht
werden kann gerade was das verhindern
neben der schweren fälle und der
todesfälle betrifft und wo ich auch
wirklich zuversichtlich bin dass die
sehr genau gucken die leiter von
einrichtungen die gesundheitsämter und
um denen die möglichkeit zu geben sich
darauf zu konzentrieren ist es eben
wichtig dass alle anderen mitmachen wir
sehen dass die anzahl unter den über
80-jährigen bei
den sind ja viel in alten- und
pflegeheim dass die inzidenz dort
ansteigt aber nicht so dramatisch wie im
frühjahr
und dass diese leute können sich in der
regel nicht so gut selber schützen
bei den summen um die 60 jährigen ist
die gar nicht so hoch die können sich
eben schon ganz gut schützen und da
müssen wir andere neben beitragen die
auch gerade die jüngeren altersgruppen
gerade auch die 15 39 uhr und 9 30 bis
60 jährigen so diese altersgruppen dass
die darauf achten dass bei ihnen auch
runter geht damit das nicht auch bei den
über 80-jährigen so hoch schießt denn
also ganz abriegeln geht dass das geht
natürlich nicht die müssen
die müssen auch versorgt werden und das
muss auch besuchsmöglichkeiten geben
also insgesamt einen bereich der großes
präventions- potenzial hat wir haben
noch ein kleines bisschen zeit wie heute
keine restriktion ist die
gebärdendolmetscherin haben sind jetzt
noch drei die ich noch mal kurz aufrufe
so weil die hand nach oben ist falls sie
keine frage stellen wollen bitte hand
einfach senken ich fange mit fouls gern
hätte noch eine frage zu den testungen
da hatten sie in jüngster zeit dazu
aufgehoben nur noch die schweren
symptomatischen fällen zu testen
bis dahin rücklauf ob das auch gemacht
wird ob das auch erfolgen
wie gesagt also das ist erst vor kurzem
geschehen das können werden das können
wir noch nicht ihnen sagen dass dafür
haben wir noch nicht genug einblicke um
zu sehen inwiefern das auswirken hat auf
das test verhalten wir gehen davon aus
dass ist das hat aber wir können das in
wir können das nicht überprüft momentan
dann frei von der bild dankeschön
sie haben eben die papst in giengen an
der wien bzw in uk gibt es eigentlich
anderen länder die sich bei ihren
empfehlungen zum mitnehmen oder auch als
abschreckendes beispiel
also wir sind kontinuierlich mit vielen
ländern dieser welt in kontakt
selbstverständlich sind für uns die whu
und das easy dc auch zwei institutionen
die ja
sehr umfänglich daten sammeln und und
daten auch auswerten und wir werden die
auch zusammen aus ja es gibt viele
länder wo man das ein oder andere sich
anschaut und und vor allen dingen
tauschen wir uns hier aus mit
kolleginnen und kollegen in diesen
ländern und und wir wir sagen was wir
für daten haben was dies oder jenes
bedeutet und wenn sie sich dann
letztlich die maßnahmen anschauen dann
sehen sie ja einfach es gibt ein
bestimmtes paket an maßnahmen und die
sind weltweit ja auch gar nicht
großartig unterschieden solange wir kein
medikament haben das direkt dieses virus
angreift und die cs daran hindert
weitere sich zu vervielfältigen und
solange wir keinen impfstoff haben sind
dass überall die gleichen maßnahmen die
dann halt nur je nach
bevölkerungsstruktur nach bevölkerungs
alter zum beispiel sind eine sehr alte
gesellschaft nigeria ich glaube der sz
durchschnittsalter also so weit unter 30
bei uns ist sehr deutlich deutlich höher
nach struktur der der gebiete gibt
flächenländer finnland oder so die haben
eine ganz andere geografische struktur
wo menschen leben und so sind die mehr
oder weniger dieselben konzepte die man
mehr oder weniger temporär dann etwas
verschoben sind in die eine oder andere
richtung aber wir sprechen immer über
über diese dinge unternehmen wir jetzt
mal ein beispiel wo wir vor kurzem
darüber gesprochen hatten
das war ein mit dem kollegen aus
schweden anders technik der uns zum
beispiel berichtete dass das öffnen der
universitäten dazu führte dass das
infektionsgeschehen verstärkt zu nah
aber nicht etwa weil die studierenden
weil die die universitäten keine gute
hygiene konzepte hatten sondern weil
eben die studierenden natürlich nach der
universitäten bestimmtes soziales leben
haben wo dann wieder intensiver der
kontakt da war dadurch wurden dann
plötzlich mehr fälle dort gemeldet das
sind eigentlich dinge die wir schon sage
mit mit normalem menschenverstand alle
nachvollziehbar sind und klar sind und
es gibt daneben gesellschaften wenn man
nach japan etwas schauen japan hat ja
bislang einen wirklich großartigen
erfolgen in japan
dort werden diese maßnahmen natürlich in
einem ganz hohen maße in dieser
kollektivistischen gesellschaft in einem
ganz hohen maße getragen von allen
menschen dort die die eben nichts als
schlimmer ansehen als dass sie einen
anderen mit menschen schädigen durch
eine infektion
das sind auch kulturelle hintergründe
die wir natürlich auch immer wissen
müssen
und insofern kann man nicht alle
konzepte hundertprozentig übertragen
aber es ist dasselbe bündel an maßnahmen
und in dem ein oder anderen landwirt
dann eben auch einfach noch strenger
umgesetzt und und exekutiert so jetzt
erst wirklich die letzte frage herr
kreutzfeldt mit der bitte um kurze frage
und kurze antwort wenn es noch zeit gibt
und wenn sie es ebenso vermisst haben
wir wieder würde ich doch noch und zwar
war es ja so dass das lka ende oktober
regelmäßig gemeldet hat dass der airport
unter 1 gesunken ist und dass dann
regelmäßig eine woche später ohne dass
man es groß mitgekriegt hat wieder
korrigiert worden ist auch deutlich über
1 und im moment ist es wieder so dass
für die letzten drei tage in dieser
tabelle noch ein wert von unter eins
steht aber für alle anderen davor ist
das nach oben korrigiert worden
nachträglich und deswegen wollte ich es
noch mal hören ob sie da dieser
derzeitigen lage wo sich gezeigt hat
dass der regelmäßig und zwar deutlich um
etwa mindestens 0,1 unterschätzt wurde
in der letzten zeit ob dieser wert
endlich sinnvoll ist zu kommunizieren
aus ihrer sicht oder ob da nicht mehr
zur verfügung beiträgt als zur klarheit
also der wert ist sinnvoll und ist ein
schätzwert und und sie wissen sie wie
sie wissen sehr gut für dieser wert
zustande kommt es ist ein schätzwert ich
denke diese kommunikation betreiben wer
immer die wird die wirtin vielleicht
nicht immer adäquat wahrgenommen wir
schreiben ja sogar in unserem
situationsbericht dass wir in den
letzten wochen eher korrigieren muss
nach oben den ärger das dass das ist das
ist der tatsache aber nochmals ist ein
schätzwert aber der wert ist schon sehr
sehr wichtig aber er ist nur dann
wichtig wenn er stabil lange zeit eine
klare tendenz zeigt denn der der wert
hängt von vielen faktoren ab wir in die
formel des notars in die berechnung der
verschiedene aspekte ein
die zeitverzögerung bei der testung die
ändert sich ja auch immer wieder wir
haben jetzt längere zeit verzögern
also das heißt der schätzwert ist
wichtig und richtig und er wird auch
deshalb in vielen ländern oder meines
wissens in allen ländern wird der wert
als eine maßzahl gegeben aber noch mal
es ist eben nur eine maßzahl und das
habe ich so häufig versucht zu sagen
auch hier
es gibt viele viele zahlen die wir
betrachten um dr wird ist einer davon
es ist nicht der eine glückselig
machenden und ich möchte und zum
abschluss noch mal sagen ich hatte
wir hatten ja mal zahlen ich glaube die
niedrigste niveau hatten waren 300 pro
tag oder so dann hatten wir plötzlich in
meck-pomm etwa wenn doch dann war da ich
weiß nicht sage ich jetzt mal zehn fälle
und dann waren an einem tag plötzlich
eben zwölf fälle dann ist der airbag
natürlich nach oben gegangen der arbeit
hat natürlich hängt in hohem maße
natürlich auch immer von dem von den
männern ab dass das ist ja ganz klar und
darum ist der er wird auch in diesem
aspekt zu betrachten aber er ist ein
wichtiger wert den werden wir weiter
kommunizieren und wir kommunizieren
ihnen vorsichtig aber wir wissen wenn er
dauerhaft und zwar ordentlich unter 1
bleibt also nicht nur mal unter 1
sondern richtig dauerhaft langfristig
weit unter 1 bleibt dann ist die tendenz
die die wir brauchen und er ist einer
von vielen ein wichtiger wert vielen
dank dann werden wir jetzt das
pressebriefing in ak ii und bis zum
nächsten mal wieder schön
[Musik]
ok